thank you
5 25 and your Monday morning what's
driving you crazy how about new rules
now in place when it comes to HOV lanes
in Las Vegas with a Twist
the Nevada Department of Transportation
has been updating freeway signs to show
that HOV lanes are no longer enforced 24
7. indots Justin Hopkins with the new
rule two passengers or more in the HOV
lanes between the hours of 5 a.m and 10
p.m 7 days a week and then after 10 pm
and before 5 a.m those lanes are open to
all drivers so anybody can use those
Lanes but there's already an exception
to the new rule and we mentioned it on
the air the other day here it is on the
overhead side the HOV opened to everyone
between Spring Mountain all the way down
to Silverado Ranch that's the general
area of indot's huge I-15 Tropicana
rebuild it's going to kick into high
gear in January because of driver
confusion about that free HOV lanes
Hopkins says what we decided to do was
make the availability of the HOV lanes
much longer and we're going to do some
restriping that double white line will
be gone for that entire stretch that'll
all be done by before Thanksgiving and
Hopkins also has some interesting
information about how ndot knows how
many people are or aren't in cars using
the HOV lanes we'll save that for our
next driving you crazy report buckle up
drive carefully please put on the phone
and join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com